Florida health officials say they have
confirmed at least a dozen cases of
canine influenza is also known as the
dog flu the h3n2 virus is believed to
have spread last month among animals at
dog shows in Florida and Georgia the
number of cases is small but some
Florida officials recommend pet owners
have their dogs vaccinated Omar
Villafranca is inside an animal hospital
in DeLand Florida
Omar good morning good morning that
Florida Dog Show was just a few miles
away from this clinic here at the DeLand
Animal Hospital they've seen a few of
those suspected cases they're being
extra vigilant telling pet owners to
keep an eye on their dogs for any
flu-like symptoms
Stephanie man Ginelli is proud of her
french mastiff they want numerous top
awards at last weekend's show but
several dogs apparently took home
something else the dog food
Stephanie's dog seemed healthy but the
vet tech decided to vaccinate them
anyway you took the precaution today yes
we did we gave her her vaccine today and
her next show in a couple weeks she'll
be nice and protective the virus first
appeared in the u.s. two years ago with
over a thousand confirmed cases in the
Chicago area at least five dogs died the
h3n2 strain has since appeared in 30
states the illness is rarely fatal but
causes sneezing coughing and nasal
discharge is highly contagious
Melissa Lawson is a vet tech at a clinic
in DeLand which pet owners need to worry
any pet owners that bring their dogs to
dog parks rooming facilities boarding
facilities dog shows if they have a very
active lifestyle where they take their
dog a lot out than they should there is
an imminent threat for dogs to be
exposed to this virus on Thursday
scientists at the University of Florida
urge dog owners here to consider getting
their pets vaccinated the more dogs in a
community that we can vaccinate the
better chance we have of keeping this
virus out of the community but skeptics
say the alarm is overstated Dana Scott
of dogs naturally magazine thinks pets
are over medicated and drug companies
profit
I think when it comes to vaccination
what you really need to think about is
where are these reports coming from it's
basically the vaccine manufacturers that
are keeping track of these diseases and
we're relying on the vaccine
manufacturers to convey that information
to us
ken Matson isn't vaccinating
eight-year-old Chloe for now but is
trying to limit close contact with other
dogs it's a major concern but it's just
something you would give an eye at this
point the American Veterinary Medical
Association says pet owners need to talk
to their vets to see if their dogs are
part of that high-risk pool it's also
worth noting there are more than 80
million dogs in the US and only several
thousand have officially been diagnosed
with the flu Norah
Omar thank you an important story they
didn't also the knowledge that there are
18 million dogs yeah in this country all
loved 80 million happy people that's
right dogs are walking happiness I love
my lucky yeah I know you do